safety concerns are being addressed for
some residents at the Los Pecos senior
apartments yeah we're happy to report
that there is help for those at the
complex over on Pecos and Russell
Madison Kimbrough reports
this is good news all around from car
and Apartment break-ins to tires being
slashed residents that live here hope
that corporate and law enforcement will
finally come through we had a great
positive meeting it seems that now we
will have security Lori cedaros is a
longtime resident at Los Pecos senior
apartments
she and her neighbors breathing a sigh
of relief after a meeting was held on
Wednesday addressing their safety
concerns the person from the corporate
office in Oregon told us that they were
working on getting cameras on the
corners of the buildings maybe motion
line so they're going to check the
lighting as well these flyers also
passed out to Residents in attendance at
the meeting Metro and GSL properties the
owner of the complex announcing they
will work with residents regarding their
concerns and will have daily security
patrol in the premises we finally got
security here one of the guys in charge
I guess of the security company spoke to
us
and said they are doing it
intermittently every day they will be
driving around and with this news
residents hoping that it's not just talk
because all they want is to feel safe
again it just brings more questions that
why did it take so long the thing is
it's the follow-through that I'm very
concerned about residents also telling
me that while security was promised it's
still unclear when and what time they
will be riding through reporting in the
East Valley Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now